Speaker 1: . We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192. David P
Here's a very interesting voicemail
our friend Juan wrote in and
talked about his doctor and he says his
doctor has some very particular beliefs
but is a very good doctor. And what do I
think about this? Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: David is one year, so the only
doctor that in my opinion, is worth a dime
or has helped me enough to where I
feel better on a day to day basis.
It's basically a doctor. Who believes that
Trump. Will be reinstated. Okay. This doctor
is a doctor that I have a lot of respect
for, a doctor that I'm willing to pay even
though I can afford without insurance. A
doctor that if I come across some lottery,
I would even give them some of my
lottery. I find myself in a situation
where. I have to go along with some of this
nonsense because I fear that if I say something.
He doesn't like that. I'll lose the
only doctor that has actually helped me.
Okay. Can you believe that? We've gotten to
the point. That we can't even. Disagree without
becoming disagreeable or even losing a friendship.
Speaker 1: Listen, as I've said before. When
people disagree about what the top tax rate should
be. It's not really the type of disagreement that
has a huge material impact on most relationships,
right? If I think, hey, we should have
that the top marginal tax rate should go all the
way up to 55%. And you believe we should have a
flat tax of 18%? All right. We just disagree. It's
not viscerally loaded in the same way that some
of these other things are on. The complete other
end of the spectrum would be beliefs like, well,
the Jews should be killed, right? If you find
me a great doctor. But the doctor believes the
Jews should be killed. It's going to be hard
for me to put that aside and say, listen,
I'm just coming in here for, you know, this is
my ophthalmologist and not to pick on Rand Paul
and that's it. And then there's a
whole bunch of in-between stuff for me,
a doctor who is so delusional that they believe
Trump is about to be reinstated. It's hard to
imagine that they are completely with it in every
other way. Now there is this I've talked about
this condition before, called paraphrase NEA
and paraphrase NEA is a mental disorder where
there's a very organized and limited system of
paranoid delusions. There's no hallucination.
The intellect doesn't deteriorate. The
personality doesn't deteriorate. So
sometimes when when you're talking about. Someone
with paranoid delusions and or schizophrenia.
You talk to them and they seem like they are not
there in every sense. Like you just say, Hey,
you know, what do you want for dinner tonight?
And it's some unintelligible rant. And there's
personality disorder and there's a breakdown
of their ability to socialize and all of these
different things. Paraphrasing here is different
in which sometimes someone has a very it's almost
like a walled off, delusional belief. It might
be. In this case, Trump's about to be reinstated.
Listen, I understand that accept the science of
climate change. I know how germ theory works.
Gravity. I've got no problem with what is a
good and bad diet. How to best raise a kid.
We agree on everything, but I have this walled off
delusion about Trump is secretly the president or
he is about to be reinstated or whatever. That's
a condition called paraphrase and that exists.
It's just usually not something like the
president who lost is about to be reinstated.
It's not that. So as far as advice to Juan, you
got to do whatever you got to do. But to me, it
seems weird that the only delusional belief would
be Trump is imminently going to be reinstated. Let
me know what you think on the bonus show today.
We are going to be recapping the primary elections
from earlier this week. We are going to talk
about a man who has tested positive for monkeypox,
COVID and HIV at the same time. It's an incredible
situation. And we will also talk about Dr. Anthony
Fauci step stepping down in December after decades
of public service and Republicans claiming he's
doing it to avoid prosecution. Prosecution for
what you might ask? Well, I don't have the answer,
but we'll try to figure it out on the bonus show.
Sign up at join Pacman icon to get instant access.